[Music]
I'm gonna start with the most important
question this is obviously a beloved
classic I mean everyone loves The Lion
King so I'm just curious it must been a
lot of people that wanted to do the work
on the film what did you pay to be in it
everything I actually used to have a
firstborn but I don't think I knew they
were doing it I was busy doing something
else so the call that I got was the call
to be in it so it was like Publishers
Clearing House I actually wanted to do
that was my question it's like what is
it like getting that phone call that
says um we want you to meet about or
we're offering you a role in The Lion
King are you like yep I mean what's that
reaction well it's just I suppose it's
it's such a great call to get you know
that you are that it's one of those
moments I think for me anyway that you
just you're aware that you'll always
kind of remember this conversation but
you know that in the moment of the
conversation which was really nice I
mean I just thought this is so exciting
I would love to I wanted to immediately
see it that's the thing you know I just
thought that's such a great idea to to
reach analemma G into this wonderful
amazing story you know over after this
period of time you know 25 years is a
significant amount of time and just to
kind of to bring all the sort of tools
and to bring all of the kind of
knowledge of that you know of life and
all of our experiences from that time
into something new and to re-energize
this story and this really wonderful
narrative you know all over again I
thought it was a great idea I'm really
happy that it's here now because from
the moment they announced the cast
people that know how movies are made was
saying how's it going how's it going to
your hands like so we're gonna see you
get sick come on I dunno so I just I put
it in the back of my head eventually I
will grow
gradually I'm very curious about the
recording process what I found
interesting about Seth and Billy is that
they recorded together did you guys ever
record together were you always on your
own I did a variation you know just well
very various options you know I did some
of my own I did some with Donald and and
then with Florence which was great
actually you know just to kind of that
you know to be able to play the scenes
in that way was really really great and
and every time that I'd go in you know
that there would be sort of different
development in how it was all coming
together how it was all rendering
together and so just to get a much more
developed sense of what they were what
it was going to look like you know and
the the the level of realism that they
were that they were gonna they were they
were gonna hit was kind of amazing and I
am very familiar with Cheney tales reach
for power so I just did mine on mine I
said I know he's gonna do I'm a big fan
of Disneyland Disney World
have you guys been and I have to ask if
you have what's like the first ride you
go to what's the thing that you have to
do small world
I've been going to Disneyland since I
was two
every two years growing up we came to
Southern California and I told my mother
when I was four she says that I said
when I'm a grown woman I'm gonna live in
Southern California and she asked me why
I said because you can go to Disneyland
anytime you want and the Sun comes out
every day so this is literally why you
alright
I didn't even think about being in the
business until I was 16
it was Disneyland that's crazy
I'll freeze an actress right now because
of Disneyland great amazing yeah um did
you ever ride that you go to have you
been no I don't I mean I I actually I I
have never been are you ki I'm sorry
everybody calm down going they might
have you up yeah
oh yeah to get this tape out there and I
gotta go okay but you should really you
should really go I think you have an
amazing friend of mine now you have to
stand in mind